it has everything to do with demon
attacks I'm going to take your question
said since my reversion Catholicism I
was attacked by demons twice both
instances were when I was fasting don't
you know why am as you go to Matthew
12434 even Satan attacked Jesus when he
was fasting don't you know why am you
were being attacked be wise as serpents
innocent harmless as dogs because your
fasting makes you more powerful in the
spirit realm the more you fast the more
you pray the more you study scripture
the more you meditate in God's word the
more you obey the more deadly you become
against Satan and the more afraid he is
of you so what do the evil spirits do
distract you in order to discourage you
from praying and fasting now if you give
in then they know how to stop you from
being a danger against the kingdom of
darkness
you get it
now and the second reason is when you're
fasting that's when you're physically
weak and if you're physically weak it
impacts you intellectually mentally
psychologically emotionally so they take
that as an opportunity to pray on you
she's physically weak because when
you're physically weak you have a hard
time staying focused because you get
agitated you want to give up so you're
not at your optimal
psychological and emotional state so
they pray on that moment seeing that you
are at a weak State and hoping that
during that moment of weakness they can
cause you to succumb stumble and sin and
grieve the Holy
Spirit you got it don't fall for their
traps and snares that should motivate
you if you're being attacked when you're
fasting that's a sign you're doing
something good because Satan won't
attack you when you're doing something
bad he'll encourage you all the more to
do something sinful and
wicked Now read Matthew
12434 when an unclean Spirit goes out
out of a man he goes through Dry places
seeking rest and finds none then he says
I will return to my house from which I
came and when he comes he finds it empty
swept and put in order then he goes and
takes with him seven other Spirits more
wicked than himself so there are spirits
that are more wicked than other
Spirits yeah finish it so then he takes
seven other Spirits more wicked than him
you understand that even in the Kingdom
Arness Darkness there are some Spirits
more wicked more vile more evil more
powerful more filthy that even other
Spirits fear them even other Spirits
stand in awe of how wicked and evil
these higher ranking Spirits happen to
be
that's spirit is something else yeah now
keep reading all the way to 45 finish it
he brings seven
more and they enter and dwell there and
then and the last state of that man is
worse than the first so shall it also be
with this wicked
generation see do you see what the Lord
saying now let me explain the point of
that
Parable the Lord Likens your heart your
soul your mind your inner person as a
house you see again because that evil
spirit left a person that evil spirit
left someone that he had possessed and
oppressed so the Lord Likens your inner
person your inner man so so to speak
your heart your mind your soul to a
house if the house is empty someone has
to occupy it so learn what the Lord is
teaching you the Lord is teaching you
you are a temple a house a home someone
must live in it if God is not living in
it then it is Satan or an evil spirit do
not de deceive yourself no human being
is empty all human beings are homes
temples for someone to dwell in so if
God is Not dwelling in it then an evil
spirit if not Satan himself will take
occupancy in your heart in your mind in
your inner
person that's what the Lord's teaching
you that's what he said when he finds
the house empty but tidied that's what
he said right you just read it correct
and put in order a house that's tidied
but still empty having no occupant then
he not only reenters that person he
brings seven more evil spirits to make
that person's life much worse than it
was before that evil spirit had left his
condition will become much worse than at
the beginning when he was occupied by
one evil spirit you remember me there
yeah so this is what the Lord is
teaching you
here what's the point
either the triun god occupies you either
the Holy Spirit indwells you and fills
you or an evil spirit does but there are
no
vacancies no human heart no human mind
no human soul can be vacant it must be
occupied by
someone you get it yeah are you seeing
it right but I want you to catch go back
to 43 4 before read when that evil
spirit left the man where did he go read
for me where you went when an unclean
Spirit goes out of a man he goes through
Dry places notice he doesn't look for
watery
places did you catch
it an evil spirit looks for
Desert parched land Wilderness it
doesn't look for watery places right
right okay now do me a favor go to Mark
5 let me show you another connection
verses 1 to
10 watch I'm going to go with this pay
attention guys evil spirits look for
Desert parched land Wilderness arid
places dry places not watery places okay
you guys listening thank the Lord Jesus
we got a good crowd so we're going to go
into some spiritual meat read Mark 5
veres 1- 10 the demoniacs
legion then they came to the other side
of the sea to the country of the go
ahead gin or gines doesn't matter you're
not goingon to visit anytime
soon and when he had come out of the
boat immediately there met him out of
the tombs a man with an unclean spirit
so he came out of what tombs a graveyard
pay attention a demoniac is coming out
of the tombs graveyard let's see who's
paying attention keep going
wow I have so many questions on that
that right alone verse three who had his
dwelling among the
tombs and no one could bind him not even
with
chains because he had often been bond
with shackles and
chains and the chains had been pulled
apart by him and the shackles broken
into pieces yep neither could anyone
tame him and always night and day he was
in the mountains and in the tombs crying
out and cutting himself with stones so
he was far away in dry AED places
mountainous regions and in the tombs
right okay keep
reading when he saw Jesus from afar he
ran and worshiped him and he cried out
with a loud voice and said what have I
to do with you Jesus Jesus Son of the
most high God I implore you by God that
you do not torture me torment me
yep all the way he said for he said to
him come out of the man unclean Spirit
then he asked them what is your
name and he answered saying my name is
Legion for we are
many also he begged him earnestly that
he would not be sent out of the
country now a large herd of swine was
feeding there near the mountains so all
the demons begged him saying send us to
the swine that we may enter them okay
now pause right there we're going to
break it down notice demons dwell in
tombs dry Eric places and occupy unclean
animals pigs they would
rather indwell swine which is an unclean
Animal by Jewish law then be driven out
of that Countryside now what's the
implication why tombs what do you find
in tombs dead
bodies why dry Aid places because
scripture
teaches if you
are spiritually
dead and you don't have the Living
Waters dwelling in you the Holy Spirit
then you don't belong to Christ why do
they like dry places because a place
that's watered represents a Heart Made
Alive by The Living Waters the Holy
Spirit John 7:38 to39 read it John 7
38-39 right here John 7 3839 this tells
you where demons dwell and what do they
like to occupy John 7
38-39 38-39 yep he who believes in me as
the scriptures has said out of his heart
will flow rivers of Living Water yep but
this he spoke concerning the spirit
whom whom the those believing in him
were received for the Holy Spirit was
not yet given because Jesus was has not
yet been glorified did you catch it
Living Waters the Waters of Life The
Springs of Living Waters Holy Spirit why
do demons like dry places parched land
AED places because that represents soil
that's not watered a heart that's dead
and not made Alive by the Holy Spirit
demons occupy spiritually dead people
who do not have the Living Waters of
Life bubbling within them unto eternal
life who do not have the Holy Spirit
that's what you're supposed to learn
from these examples evil spirits occupy
people who are not born of the spirit
who are dead in their trespasses
enslaved to sin those who are Made Alive
who are dead are now made alive who are
now born of the spirit and have the Holy
Spirit indwelling them the spring of the
Waters of Life they are occupied by God
not by demons not by evil spirits go to
Colossians 2:
11-13 we'll talk about the pigs in a
minute okay if you go to Colossians 2
11:13 and him you are also circumcised
with the circumcision made without hands
by putting off the body of the sins of
the flesh by circumcision of Christ
buried with him in baptism in which you
also raised with him through faith and
the working of God who raised him from
the dead
so and you finish it all the way 13
finish it and when being dead in your
trespasses and the uncircumcision of
your flesh he has made alive again
together with him having forgiven you
all trespasses okay so notice someone
who is spiritually Dead who doesn't have
the spring of the Water of Life the Holy
Spirit right that is soil that is land
that evil spirits occupy but once you
turn to Christ now you have the spring
of the Water of Life indwelling you the
Holy Spirit who now makes you alive
unites you to Christ now you have God
filling you and occupying you so what's
the point to learn from these examples
evil spirits look for dead people who
are dry and do not have the spring of
the water of life living in them who are
not born of the spirit who do not have
the spirit who do not belong to the
spirit and therefore are not United to
Christ are you catching the implication
of why an evil spirit goes and looks for
a dry AED place or why these evil
spirits drove the man to a graveyard to
a tomb because those physically dead
bodies signified his condition that like
them he's dead but he's dead spiritually
while they're dead physically is it all
making sense or no if you're not born of
the spirit that means you're dry
spiritually and you're dead spiritually
but if you have the Holy Spirit you're
now alive spiritually and you have
Living Waters flowing within you that's
spiritual Waters meaning the Holy Spirit
the spirit is likened to water why
because water refreshes you water
cleanses you water gives you life no
water you die likewise without the Holy
Spirit you're dead without the Holy
Spirit you can't be cleansed without the
Holy Spirit you can't be refreshed so no
better apt metaphor for the spirit than
water I don't drink water I die I have
no water I'm
dirty right so water cleanses me
refreshes me without water I can't live
likewise the Holy Spirit refreshes me
purifies me and without the Holy Spirit
I can't
live so what an app metaphor for the
spirit right so now let's talk about now
Judea Christian you got it I didn't know
I'm sorry I thought you were trouble
thank the Lord Jesus you're not I hope
you got it now
now why pigs because according to the
law according to the law pig is an
unclean animal again note the connection
evil spirits only indwell that which is
unclean that which is clean is indwelt
by God you catch it now why are they
asking the Lord drive us into the herd
of pigs because as far as the law is
concerned these were considered unclean
animals unfit for God's covenant people
to consume under the Mosaic Covenant so
again what's the point here you're
supposed to see that demons only andwell
occupy that which is
unclean
right okay but now notice the reaction
of the swine the
swine ran off the cliff into what what
did they when they when the unclean
Spirits unto them they ran off the cliff
into what if you read Mar Mark 5 into
what water right the very thing evil
spirits
hate so note what the Lord is showing
you here even an unclean animal would
rather die than be possessed by an evil
spirit even an unclean animal has enough
common sense to not want to be possessed
by an evil spirit and yet human beings
are comfortable being possessed by evil
spirits wrecking havoc on their
life isn't that
amazing so note the very place that evil
spirits hate to to IND to dwell watery
places is where they ended up anyway and
what was the cause of them being driven
to a watery Place unclean animals who
had enough common sense to rather die
than to have evil spirits possess
them and yet human beings who are
supposed to be more sensible are okay
with evil spirits possessing them and
Wrecking havoc on their lives is that
amazing yeah are you guys catching the
point another Point you're supposed to
see that God values human life more than
animal life if there's a choice between
a human dying or an animal Dying God
will allow an animal to die over against
a human because God loves humans more
than animals so whereas the Lord did not
allow evil spirits to occupy a human
being created in His image he did allow
them to occupy animals because animals
are less in worth and value in the sight
of God than human beings God loves
humans more than animals it's not he
hates animals but if he's going to
sacrifice one over the other animals we
sacrifice in order to spare a human
soul so hope you got the point I don't
know if that made sense yeah it did so
and all this goes back to using your
sister as an example a perfect
illustration even though her life her
life is about
to just become hell it's spinning out of
control in spite of all that she's
currently going through and it's going
to get much worse instead of com coming
to senses and turning to Jesus and
asking the spirit to fill her and
cleanse her of this unclean influence
she'd rather continue this path of
Destruction showing she has less sense
than even a herd of swine that the
moment they came in contact with evil
spirits they chose death rather than to
be occupied by unclean spirits
you catch it yeah